welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question it's the show that
gives you too much information about
those characters who foolishly roll into
our uncanny valley where they incur the
wrath of fans armed with that marriage
watch joining me filling in for Phillip
Melina is marina Mastro's ripped his
shirt so he's had to stay home and sew
it back together that's good you think
you just have tons of shirts on him at
all times for when that inevitably
happens it happens all the time but he
likes to so he's the sower
he's a sower and a show speed the name
of the game today marina so hit me with
the big question is oh he could run it
turns out so let's talk about Sonic's
speed now that his film is coming it's
it's honest it's upon us and he's all
over us
all right sonic speed is let's be honest
it's a primary thing people think about
or care about with him his name sonic is
taken from the term sonic boom which is
what happens when a moving object goes
faster than the speed of sound and it
creates this shock wave called a sonic
boom and a sound barrier is hit at 767
miles per hour and traditionally that
speed and speed of sound has been
reported as Sonic's top speed that's why
he's called Sonic and that's been
traditionally his speed in the games
yeah obviously his main move is to curl
into a ball and run into stuff yeah so
he's deadly
he's a deadly speedster and that's what
his move is is just to roll through you
unless there are spikes and if he
touches them he loses all of his race
now this sonic movie appears to be doing
some real freaky freaky [ __ ]
Sonic's abilities and this is aside from
the freaky appearance that he had in the
original trailer so Sonic in this movie
it appears can throw a ring that opens a
portal that allows him to tell Roger
Rabbit like Roger Rabbit and that's a
lot of the humor of this movie right
like fish out of water cartoon character
all around the real world blah blah blah
here he comes from his game world yeah
that seems to be based on the Sega games
and he spills into our world and the
power that he has seems to be
target by nefarious entities who want to
use it for weapon purposes so when he is
moving you can see in the in the trailer
and in all the footage clips he was seen
he gives out this electrical energy
right and this looks like the speed
force that you see with the flash you
know when he runs it and that allows him
to like screw around with timelines and
change history and stuff Sonics case he
has his own mythology and it's called
the chaos energy ok so it's an energy
force that emits from Sonic and it emits
from every Chaos Emerald and it allows
once to turn your thoughts into power
it's kind of like their force it
surrounds everything and binds
everything and it's really kind of like
the central energy source for all the
games so like Sonic and his buddies use
the positive side of it for good and
then other bad guys use the negative
side of chaos energy for evil purposes
like you do like you do I mean you
really should just use it for you'll do
so much more so much more dark side of
the force is a pathway to many abilities
maybe this movie will call this energy
force chaos energy like sonic leaves a
hair behind and then Robotnik's socks
just tug on it you know you lick a hair
when if I do that's the only way you
know whose it is
hmm this chaos energy if we're gonna
call it that emits from Sonic when he
moves too fast and in the yeah he runs
around the bases when he plays baseball
by himself because he's lonely and does
a lot of things so it releases this
power surge that knocks out the power
grids for the entire Pacific Northwest
now remember that because it comes back
later that's actually not a good thing
that that happens yeah he rolls and it
releases the chaos energy that knocks
over a speed truck so what does all of
this tell us about Sonic's actual speed
well a scene from the movie does clock
him at moving 760 miles per hour passes
speedometer which is 7 miles per hour
shy of breaking the sound barrier so
it's probably like oh we can move
at the cusp of a sound barrier seems
traditional however there is another
scene that shows him clearly breaking
the sound barrier releasing a sonic boom
shock wave that devastates the
surrounding terrain and we learned in
our Hulk thunderclap episode that if you
were beside a sonic boom and closely
proximity to it the decibel level alone
will cause the air to be pressurized and
cause you to cough up blood and
potentially choke on blood so that's not
safe for anything within the proximity
of that sonic so pilots just wearing
like crazy headphones like when Sonic's
goes when pilots goes through a sonic
boom they are moving at the sonic boom
there with ya so they aren't in the
surrounding area but yeah there are some
low flying jets that can like shatter
glass and start from the South raisi
okay but what's even crazier is because
I know where this is going and I'm
worried bring it on
because sonic games tend to just
increase his relative speed depending on
what the storyline of the game requires
them to move yeah so in Sonic Unleashed
some checkpoints o'clock sonic Edit 2800
87 miles per hour but further increased
to 3,000 miles per hour
everyone's dead so everyone is dead okay
the Sonic Adventure DX manual lists
Sonic as potentially double hypersonic
so hyper sonic is in excess of Mach 5
which is three thousand eight hundred
and forty miles per hour so double that
seven thousand six hundred and eighty
miles per hour so let's back up from the
numbers here to put this in context that
we can understand so have you seen the
boys and that's all you need to know
because the opening scene of the series
shows a train yeah running through a
woman now a train is a speedster like
the flash and the numbers that they've
given him is later when he does that
test track thing the announcer says he
can run in excess of a thousand miles
per hour that's Mach 1.3 okay so we
thought what he did yeah should we
actually reenact what happened yeah so
they're holding hands
yeah and then you're I'll be Robin
the stupid Billy Joel post with me
imagine these are hands has her hands so
the rest of her body blown to simoleons
a trans movement and a speed was visible
you know you still saw a blur that
swiped Robin out of frame here's where
things get crazy her sonic here once
seen depicts sonic freezing time in the
movie so there's a shot where missiles
are closing in on ya if you look closely
those missiles are not even moving he's
tapping his foot he swats them all down
like they're whacking moles their
missiles aren't even moving ever so
slowly there's no pixel difference like
in yeah an x-men Days of Future past in
Flash's Justice League it's absolutely
you can see things moving and if he were
to just let like bullets fly they
eventually would hit people but so he
has like plenty of time but he didn't
freeze time like a like bother time but
you know this is actually consistent
with Sonic's abilities in the game oh
because he develops the ability to move
at light speed into freeze time he gets
the power to do the light speed - uses a
light speed choose which it's just
really really fast it's visible it's
considered he can move at light speed in
order for Sonic to move so fast that
from his perspective time is standing
still inversely he must be moving at a
speed that from the outside world's
perspective is so fast that his
movements cannot be perceived by the
naked right here under that mountain in
back watch me do it again yeah so how
fast do you have to move for that to be
the case well the perceivers brain would
have to not have enough time to process
any light reflecting off the object and
if done experiments with Air Force
pilots that they were still able to
recognize an image of a plane in a far
far distance that was flash on a screen
for as little as one 220th of a second
so for
to be invisible a passing object would
have to flash before your eyes at for
the most 100 one out of two one at 250th
of a second before your brain never
picked it up it's too bad so for
something to be moving so fast that it's
invisible
the numbers are it must be moving at at
least 17,000 500 meters per second or
38,000 146 miles per hour
so if he's running the dirt underneath
him like he just destroys the plan oh
yeah because the force yeah that is
applied causes things to explode around
him that's where we get to with
Lightspeed obviously Lightspeed is truly
imperceptible when you turn on a light
you don't see the beam move across the
room it's it's instantaneous unless
we're in that scene in the mummy where
they angle the mirrors around and like
they'll be like a thirty goes to do the
slow or man beam of light so Lightspeed
super fast obviously the fastest thing
we know of is 670 million six hundred
sixteen thousand six hundred twenty nine
miles per hour
so if Sonic could travel at the speed of
light he could run around the earth
seven and a half times in one second
that's if he has Lightspeed according to
good I mean this is why you gotta be
careful just throwing around oh oh you
can run at Lightspeed because that's
insane seven and a half times in one I
gotta go
cuz he's already murdered you it's gotta
go guys Ted we're talking about the
poured dirt well what about the poor
living things Eddie yes
studies have been done to research what
would happen if one were hit by a bullet
just moving at one percent of the speed
of light at least about you know six
point seven million miles per hour now
the bullet in real life would explode if
it was moving that fast and that's what
should happen to Sonic's body right you
know he's got that chaos energy I broke
his legs rest you give him a finger okay
yeah yeah yeah there you go
so hypothetically a bullet moving add 1%
of the speed of light would be a
projectile with over 40 6.9 terajoules
which is over half of the energy
expended by the atomic bomb over
Hiroshima which was 67 terajoules
so at just 1% of light speed Sonic's
movement would create an impact blast
that could level a small city but it
gets worse other thought experiments
have explored what would happen if
Superman punched you at the speed of
light assuming Superman's fist is about
300 grams and he can move at 99% of the
speed of light that would equate to 190
quadrillion joules which is two thousand
eight hundred times more powerful than
Hiroshima
that's a temperature of 144 trillion
degrees Fahrenheit so Sonic is listed as
35 kilograms so if he hits something at
light speed he would obliterate a small
country and murder Millions yeah like it
would turn into glitter mmm to use our
favourite example they would be Sarah
Connor in t2 and will just turn into
dust immediately coming back to this
whole thing of the Pacific Northwest
power grid beam yes we don't know if the
rules are applied but we do know what
happens when grids of power get out
people die yeah a Reddit user when the
first ruler came out
study the shot of the power grids
throughout the Pacific Northwest
including places like Seattle Portland
Vancouver estimated that according to
medical and demographic data hospitals
in that region would have a total of 491
newborn babies connected to life support
at the time of Sonics power 491 babies
died because Sonic wanted to play
himself in baseball shoot that's how
fast this guy moves if Sonic runs past
you on a country road at his top speed
it will at best cause you to choke on
blood at worst will fry you in a
thermonuclear blast and everyone else
within a country size and even if it's
just chaos energy that emits and they
don't apply the rules of physics show
speed well they can't hundreds of babies
they're gonna be like you can't have
this be a movie like the internet saved
us once right from his human teeth but
now the Internet has to save us again
from what is the word for killing all of
Matias is specious I like that side yeah
planetside Earth decide like this
[ __ ] is gonna kill us all you
know now I'm kind of siding with Jim
Carrey's Robotnik if I see this movie
and when I see this movie I will be
screaming throughout the whole thing I'd
be like well there you have it Sonic's
speed is immeasurable and deadliest my
god whoa hey before we continue with
some more bite-sized questions from
marina it is February now and one of my
new year's resolutions in 2020 was to
start being smarter about how I use my
money I have so so little of it so I
have to be smarter 2020 it's a perfect
time to start thinking about 2040 with
Robin Hood you can invest in the markets
and earn interest with a competitive APY
on uninvested cash they make it easy to
get started and learn as you grow with
an intuitive app experience and no
Commission fees on trades and stock
prices don't have to hold you back you
can buy a piece of a company you love
for as low as $1 and build your
portfolio a little bit at a time buy one
share buy half a share three and a
quarter shares it's up to you your
budget and your goals your first stock
is on the house when you set up your
account go to big question dot Robin
Hood calm to learn more and claim your
free stack annual percentage yield APY
on uninvested cash is paid by program
banks and is variable robin and
financial is not a bank and the free
stock offer is subject to terms and
conditions all investments involve risk
other fees may apply just visit our be
in HD CEO slash fees actually have Robin
Hood oh you didn't get a free stock oh
yeah it was like do you want free stock
and I was like yes I do free stock we
have a success case right here we have a
millionaire round you're sitting on a
pile of money it's not a chair it's a
pile of money thanks Robin okay let us
now move on to some more bait C's
Cushing that marinas gonna nibble with
my car with my tiny Club Austin Chavis
asks
what happened to Luke's green lightsaber
in Return of the Jedi okay so in Return
of the Jedi Luke throws the saber away
when he's like I'll never join the dark
side of the blue and you can hear it
clatter there's a clatter so it doesn't
go over the edge you can hear it go to
two just like that Boop Vader kills the
Emperor Luke gets it back presumably
because it's just like over there
somewhere in the last Jedi Luke has it
in the flashback oh that's right yes Ben
Solo in the rise of Skywalker Luke is
using it when he's training Leia so it's
there as well so they obviously kept it
when Rey hands Luke back his original
lightsaber which is blue he takes any
throws it away we can assume that when
he has the green lightsaber and he gives
up being a Jedi and he's like I'm gonna
sit on this island forever that he
throws it away to so he's like a baby
when you hand him a toy he's gonna throw
it don't hand them that light this is
non cannon okay
but Mark Hamill as inspiration for
himself like just as an actor he said
that in his mind he made up this story
where he meets a single mom and
potentially I don't know I mean it goes
against his like vows but Anakin did
that too so maybe maybe Palpatine we
know we don't know if he so he meets a
single mom this mom as a kid and the kid
gets ahold of Luke's green lightsaber
and accidentally kills himself like like
if you give a kid a gun like the gun in
your house right so if you're if you
pick up a lightsaber and you're looking
down the barrel all the lights
everything you press the button that's
horrible
but that's non-canon right this is Mark
Hamill's like this is my backstory
that'll motivate my emotional motivated
for his emotional state so in his mind
he was like then he destroyed that
lightsaber out of guilt we know what
happened in Mark Hamill's mind to it and
we know that he is a tenant his
character has a tendency to throw things
away so it might be in the ocean yeah
get some scuba gear
maybe those those nuns that are on the
island the caretakers find it yeah maybe
they have it somewhere they were [ __ ]
around
okay Deathstroke four seven six nine
asks in Captain America Civil War during
Peggy Carter's funeral one pallbearer
has gray hair could that be old cap I
remember this
okay yeah yeah um you know next question
okay so it looks like it could be capped
from the back but a set photo actually
shows us the front side and it's a
totally different actor he has a
mustache it's a different person
however you could argue like oh maybe
it's cap with mustache like he parted us
on the other side maybe he got a
mustache to hide himself like he's like
I can't run into myself so but I'm gonna
go to the same funeral where I know I
know
so dumb well I also don't like this
version if it is him because that means
that we have to go with it's the same
timeline that Kevin went back on it's
the same timeline and that is
problematic because that means he sat
out a bunch of like really horrible
events horrible things happen yeah dated
his like grandniece know which means
that we go with the alternate timeline
for endgame which is what the director
is safe so narf
lastly hairy ass or hurry asks what
happened to Wakanda in the five years
that T'Challa was dusted was remonda
trying to run things for five years or
was she dusted - okay so - Charlie and
Sheree were dusted okay that's for sure
Queen remonda and mbaku are alive for
right they stayed alive when there's a
vacancy in the king role the the
leadership role you do a warrior Falls
ritual to see who will be the new leader
so it's presumable that mbaku would try
to get that title cuz he challenged at
all in the face right he was like the
runner up
yeah he's the runner up and he was
really close to winning its presumable
that into Charles absence he would come
back do it again and either be totally
on challenge because everyone was like I
saw this last time like I'm not like you
good yeah or he would be challenged but
then still went yeah cause he's a bad
cuz he was second place with the whole
kill monger thing in boxer and also in
the battle against Thanos like he came
together in the end and he was like okay
cool so he's a hero again
yeah it's respected super pop super
popular super pops dude yeah and also
just like be stand up
guy and rule for the next five years and
like hold down the fort we understand it
like there's now a power struggle when
de chollet comes back he's like even
gone for five years my friend right I've
been kicking ass here he's like GDP is
up you're sure you want to come back
thanks for kind of shitty he's like we
instituted universal basic income you
got a couple old or dark things we are
human rights violations trains run on
time the trains run on time move on to
some mailbag question feeling the boss
now I don't have to think about a sonic
Roger Caston I'm ready to get personal
and weird here we go Cappy kid asks do
you care about sports um me I do I grew
up in LA I love the Dodgers love the
Lakers I played soccer for like 11 or 12
years so I like it I like a lot I like I
like I like I like I care about sports
maybe we should have known you because
they don't I do care about the sports I
know I I used to assess because when I
went to college I went to University of
Florida which that's like we were
winning national championships an SEC
Championship so it's like you had to
care and that's what you need if you
want to like care about a particular
sport you just pick one team and you
obsess over them and then you learn
about everything else in the league and
you learned about the different
conferences so for like a good six or
seven years of my life I did obsess over
everything college football even after I
was done with college I was gonna say
six or seven years are you a doctor no
no you can't be a doctor and you can't
be a doctor in Florida is there any way
even the doctors they're still guessing
I'm glad they exist and I should care
more about them because I feel like
they'd be a nice escape but it's hard I
can't be an obsessive fanboy and care
about analytics also track all the
Marvel Comics and every movie that's
coming out so did you play anything I
was on swim team in high school I did
cut out hey yeah black belt Wow I don't
remember anything about it oh my god it
stopped right before I started get it
going through puberty it's my whole body
changed and I've became awkward and I
don't ever stop being uncoordinated I'll
bet it would
come back if you're under pressure we
should test that out next question Julio
asks what's the story behind Eric having
a cold sore and his head shot should I
go get it yeah let's go get the head
shot so you start telling them I'll go
get it in a recent episode of rogue
theory I want a golden Rogge and
off-the-wall yeah first time a golden
Brody was revealed and my head shot for
whatever reason is on the back wall I
think I got the most accurate theory in
a past episode and I I realized as I
looked at it that I had a cold sore
right here on the lip it's red it's a
it's not flattering and I don't like
this photo one bit but it's the best
photo that I had from that round of
photos the person who edited your
headshots should have taken it out they
should have because you do touch-ups
that's part of it but you can also see
like there is some head acne there
there's some dry skin at the scalp they
let you take a picture with your collar
flipped up like that well here is the
story behind it so one year Phillip and
I and a bunch of before me rock stars we
all went to VidCon so we may have met
some of you there I love VidCon it's
wonderful and one thing that they were
doing nice for some of the youtubers is
to take head shots that you can use and
the people taking a head shots were
great they were chill folks but they're
used to dealing with like vloggers like
lifestyle influencers and people who
like have it's not their personality
okay you know a year and a half ago I
was just like well how many more Easter
eggs in one case we make jokes and then
people in the comments be like stop
making jokes just stick to the facts
[ __ ] I'm sorry for any personality so
when I go in there they kind of kind of
ask you like so what kind of videos do
you make and I'm like oh we do like
movie analysis and in theory videos were
like so you're a movie critic and I said
nope didn't hear and I said I knew
Easter egg videos and they're like ha ha
so you like watching movies what's your
favorite movie and I'm like they're like
yes it is yep I kind of like get out
again they're like oh I didn't see that
one I'm like we'll be talking to seek it
out don't get out the thing is this is
it's happening
room in the Anaheim Convention Center
where it's this nice moody light room
and all the screens are covered with
people who previously had their
headshots taken in a previous round
before you and they glam you up they
give you these cool jean jackets and
other stuff to wear so it's like it was
another youtuber right who I know who's
a friend of mine who was covering the
screens he looked more [ __ ] than
I've ever seen him I he would looked
great I'm like I cannot wait to have my
pictures up on the screen when it's the
next turn they for whatever reason
they're like do you ever wear hats and
I'm like no not usually
and they're like well we have this
fedora we had this other like newsy boy
cap that like bald dudes wear and I'm
like plenty of plenty of hair they put
me in a [ __ ] hat and it's this ugly
olive green hat there's no hat it's one
of the few ones that had no hat and it's
so I'm uncomfortable and Philip is
behind the camera laughing because you
can see how uncomfortable I look and
he's like none of these are working and
they say that they're gonna put they're
gonna send you their like best one that
they do touch-ups on two weeks later I
get the best one and it's the one with
the [ __ ] hat where I'm frowning and
covering my face that's what they
thought was the best most flattering
picture I was doing this was doing this
pose I was so awkward and then after I
was done they didn't put up any of my
photos because clearly I'm uncomfortable
this was the only one that was decent
and that's why it's not touched up
because they didn't touch it up so it's
but it's the only one where I don't
cringe when I look at it but I do have a
cold sore on my lip I'm not saying
they're bad photographers they just I
just didn't connect with them other
people had great headshots so clearly
they're capable of doing it it's just I
had a disc okay but you don't cover your
face you do if you're a movie critic
okay so that's that story and then we
have one more question from Kailyn bc
who asks what happened to past hosts of
new rock stars like capo rider and true
Coolidge were they murdered yes yep I
know both those guys they're friends of
mine we both are friends with drew and
Gabe I knew in college what happened a
game new rock stars really scaled down
and we went on like life support for a
couple months so there was just like no
more work and he's like I'm kind of
ready to
I'm tired of doing this stuff he has
like a wife and a beautiful family and
he's a very smart guy his wife is a very
smart person too I'm not sure what
they're doing but like I told them on
social media and they looked like
they're having a very happy life I'm
very happy for them
drew Coolidge I don't know why he
stopped doing this I was on an improv
team with him or still am actually and I
had no idea he did this until you said
also on big questions that he got your
job who didn't deserve it but he did
improv for a long time with me here in
LA he doesn't do that anymore
because he's getting a PhD in
communications in Texas and he has a
lovely wife was very funny she doesn't
prove - now they're hilarious
she's a nurse it's great like they're
they're also thriving yeah they have
dogs yeah they've dogs like that yeah
it's so funny and we're just here we're
here we're still trapped in the blue
dungeon a couple days a week
yeah trapped in this dungeon more days a
week that dungeon another day of the
week so hey no regrets right we're doing
great
we're having fun someone will murder us
or maybe Sonic will just jog yeah I
don't know how he survived until this
boy's I've just been drinking paint
thinner hey thanks for joining us of
this week's episode of the big question
thank you to marina for subbing in for
Phillip did a great job it was a great
job and a Philip we'll be back next week
we might have a new special guest
joining Philip now hopefully they figure
it out okay work it out it's about time
you can always send us your big
questions using the hashtag big
questions on social media follow us at
New York source on all social media
subscribe to new rock stars here on
YouTube and if you love this show
not just like it not just comments
saying that you love it share it around
to your friends that's how we gotta get
the word out on this because we want to
be doing more of this stuff asking more
of these questions because I love doing
this kind of research even though it
scares me scuse me all right
and you can get a big question wherever
you get your podcasts thanks
joining and we'll see you next time we
do the erequest yeah perfect it's
perfect
[Music]